good afternoon everyone my name is dr.
Miller and the SCP we're going to be
looking at today is SCP 28:45 threat
level black object class Keter special
containment procedures use of outsourced
containment resources and consultants
has been authorized for the containment
of SCP 2845 consultants are to be
considered level 2 personnel and are at
no time permitted to leave site 100 if
at any time an outside consultant must
be removed from containment of SCP 28:45
Class A amnestics are to be applied
before release a minimum of 30 trained
individuals and an unhindered supply of
untrained subjects is required for
proper containment of SCP 28:45 48
trained personnel are currently assigned
to active containment of SCP 28:45 split
into eight teams of six with a further
24 individuals available as replacements
an allowance of 5 d class per week has
been authorized for the containment of
SCP 2845 site 100 has been constructed
to the following specifications site 100
consists of nine concentric circular
bands designated ring a through ring i
but a gap located between ring c and
ring deep designated as gap 1 sects
circular chambers are located at 0 60
120 180 240 and 300 degrees within each
ring and gap the chamber is located at 0
degrees are aligned with geographic
north to additional circular chambers
are located outside of ring eye located
at 120 and 240 degrees the floor of each
circular chamber contains an
unobstructed lead hexagram
the central chamber containing a CP 28
45 and 216 instances of scp-2059
atmosphere of 96.3% hydrogen 3.25%
helium and point 45 percent ammonia
maintained at minus 110 degrees Celsius
and a pressure of two point three bar
the following procedures are all to be
carried out in a repeating cycle of 63
hours 54 minutes each procedure is to
last 39 minutes with 10 hours between
each procedure each procedure must be
carried out by six individuals the
location of each procedure is denoted in
parentheses at the beginning of each new
cycle containment procedures will be
carried out in the next ring closest to
the containment chamber ceremonial
recitations for all procedures and
descriptions of all variant costumes may
be found in document 28 45 C exp
procedure 410 constantan 60 degrees
containment specialists are presented
with masks joy sadness anger apathy fear
and foolishness and act out ceremony
constant in a ceremony constant an a is
a farcical comedy of errors an exchange
of insults between the six individuals
culminating in foolishness outwitting
the group in a game of riddles and
declaring himself King the conclusion of
ceremony constantan a is followed by a
game of dice the winner of the game is
irrelevant to the procedure
procedure 420 Perrin although 120
degrees performance of a musical piece
for flute oboe clarinet French horn
timpani and bass drum the piece is
accompanied by specific somatic and
vocal components carried out by the
players throughout the performance
designated ceremony Paranal doe a the
performance must be live recordings of
the piece have no effect procedure for
30 Epimetheus 180 degrees gifts are
exchanged among containment specialists
content of gifts is irrelevant to the
procedure but each gift must not exceed
four dollars 28 cents in worth each gift
is accompanied by recitation of ceremony
Epimetheus a in its entirety and the
scattering of grain around the
containment chamber procedure 440
Cassiel 240 degrees ceremony Cassiel a
is recited as containment specialists
bind their feet with wool and consume
0.5 liters of olive oil then they will
break apart a rock weighing at least 200
kilograms with hammers ceremony Cassiel
b is recited throughout procedure 450
cairo 300 degrees ad class subject is
prepared by painting a symbol ring
surrounding a dot with an arrow pointing
upwards at the 90 degree point on the
stomach with a platinum based solution
and presented with a blue cloak crown
and scepter d class subject is then
restrained in a chair and ceremony cairo
a is recited after recitation of the
ceremony cairo a d class subject is to
be castrated by use of a hand sickle by
a containment specialist the testes are
then to be disposed of in a bowl of salt
water as ceremony Cairo B is recited
procedure for 60 um Phyllis 0° ceremony
omphalos a is to be recited before
roasting of a child no more than three
months of age ceremony omphalos Bea's to
be recited before consumption after
consumption of the child ceremony aunt
Phyllis C is to be recited over the
gastroliths which are then swallowed
vomiting is then induced and ceremony
aunt Phyllis D is recited signaling the
beginning of a new cycle in the case of
a containment breach site one hundreds
nuclear device is to be detonated
followed by a lockdown of all foundation
facilities and activation of protocol
28:45 XK one strike down the moon and
this is a message from containment
consultant to site director Dell on
January 31st 2012 towering Qadhafi my
home I have been approached several
times already in regards to the
containment procedures and their
complexity I have been asked if all of
the containment procedures are truly
necessary if they could not be cut down
or edited for simplicity and at least
one claim that they were patently
ridiculous
this is my response and I expect that it
will be seen by all of the foundation
staff working on this project I will not
repeat myself and I find it sickening
that after all the struggle to contain
this creature
pencil-pushing bureaucrats are still
seeking to cut corners where they cannot
afford to be cut
the answer is no the ritual will remain
as it is and will not be changed in any
way
it cannot be cut down further nor can it
be added to it has been set in place and
now that it has begun
any deviation at all could very easily
be catastrophic rituals do not work
because of some underlying laws such as
those that science operates on rituals
work because they are rituals they work
because an arbitrary set of criteria has
been met with exacting care belief that
meeting these arbitrary criteria
achieves a certain end assigns power to
the ritual the actions that were once
meaningless now have been assigned
meaning through their repetition and
application this is how one seals away
our God and this is a god I know that
the foundation does not approve of using
this term but it is still the case the
stag is a god and that is not a petty
local god it is not one of the mild gods
of Earth or some weaker spirit that is
bound by the strength of man's belief we
have for the time being fooled it into
thinking that we have overpowered it it
does not understand that we do so
falsely it is a God for God's words have
power ritual and belief hold greater
power over a god than all the laws of
science however it must be kept in mind
that the stag could escape right now if
it so chose with a thought this entire
facility could turn into a puff of
hydrogen if at any point the stag
thought to escape it would and we would
be powerless to stop it however it will
not think to escape or even to change
its strategy the idea will not even pass
through its mind it cannot comprehend
the concept it does not think in the way
we think truth be told I would not say
it thinks at all this is an old God it
does not dabble in decisions decisions
are for creatures who may act
erratically variably or out of line a
god of this strength simply is it is an
absolute it acts as a force in building
this ritual we have shifted its being
the slightest bit and now it is locked
into a pattern of behavior it struggles
against us we struggle against it and we
are locked together in an eternal dance
so long as the ritual remains intact if
one thing goes awry the entirety is lost
and the deadlock is broken unstoppable
force without an immovable object the
rituals might seem to be nonsense but
they are what I defined to be the best
course of action there are powerful
symbols there and whether or not you
think they are appropriate to this
situation is irrelevant I have listened
to the converted and I have listened to
the echoes of the stag in their songs
they are not suffering but they are no
longer human they are changed utterly
the ritual remains as it is
description SCP 28:45 is a Quadra ped
entity measuring 2.9 meters in height at
the shoulder and weighing 815 kilograms
a sinuous neck generally held in an
upright position extends a further 0.5
metres terminating in a head with
humanoid facial features SCP 28:45
possesses antlers measuring four point
eight meters across antlers are white
with black marbling and coloration and
have not been observed to shed SCP 2845
is covered in hair with an average
length of 10 centimeters with the
exception of the face which is hairless
SCP 28 45 s coloration is primarily a
pastel green with a stripe of cream on
the underside of the neck and belly a
ring of ice particles is suspended 15
centimeters behind a CP 2845 sculpt
measuring 1.7 meters in diameter with a
ring thickness of 35 centimeters this
ring is interrupted at regular intervals
by seven spheres consisting of metallic
hydrogen and metallic helium each
measuring 15 centimeters in diameter the
ring and spheres rotate clockwise at a
speed of 1.6 rpm the force maintaining
the movement of the ring the physical
state of the spheres and the means by
which SCP 2845 is capable of supporting
its head under the weight of its antlers
are unknown as CP 28:45 is capable of
instantaneous transmutation and
reconstruction of matter no matter is
created or destroyed during this process
this property is manifested at will with
an observed range extending to targets
within eyesight maximum range of this
ability is unknown transmuted matter
will remain stable despite the lack of
other factors for example metallic
hydrogen and helium are common results
which will remain in either solid or
liquid form despite the surrounding
temperature
altered atmosphere will not mix with
unaltered regions maintaining chemical
consistency
the most common transmutation results
are the solid or liquid forms of
hydrogen and helium the conversion of
atmosphere into a hydrogen helium
ammonia mix and the transmutation of
plant life into metallic based organisms
SCP 2845 will typically surround itself
with a transmuted area with a radius of
approximately 5 meters at all times SCP
2845 has proven itself completely
resistant to physical damage the most
common forms of offensive transmutation
used by SCP 2845 are a column measuring
5 to 7 meters in diameter and 60 to 80
metres in height or a horizontal cone
measuring between 100 and 150 metres in
length and 10 to 30 metres in width
at the furthest end however SCP 28:45
has been observed to attack single
targets at distances of up to 10
kilometers early observation of SCP 2845
during recovery indicated that it will
generally ignore non-combatants focusing
on retaliation against attackers
however SCP 2845 was not seen to make
any attempts to spare non-combatants
within the area of effect of its
transmutations and later recovery
accounts indicate pre-emptive attacks
against both military and civilian
targets SCP 2845 1 designates human
beings that have been modified by a CP
28:45 instances of scp-2401 are
hexagonal columns measuring 2.4 meters
in height with a rubbery yellow
green-skinned SCP 28 45 one instances do
not have any outward sense organs and
autopsy has shown that internal organs
are likewise absent save the brain which
now takes up the entirety of the column
and contains the reconstituted mass of
the other organs and some additional
outside materials it is unknown how is
CP 28 45 one instances derived nutrients
or if any nutrition is required
neuroimaging of SCP 2845 one specimens
has revealed that the brain is in a
constant state of high activity analysis
of multiple specimens indicates patterns
of call-and-response
so some form of remote communication
between a CP 28:45 one specimens is
presumed modal variants of SCP 2845 one
have been reported but have evaded
capture and study addendum one an
abridged timeline of SCP 2845 from
initial discovery to containment is as
follows
November 27 2011
initial signing of comet C 2011 W 3
December 1st 2011 comet C 2011 W 3
confirmed by Mount John University
Observatory December 2nd 2011 comet C
2011 W 3 confirmed and named by the
Minor Planet Center December 16 2011
comet C 2011 w 3 reaches perihelion
Solar Dynamics Observatory records
images of a fragment breaking off from
the main body of the comet maintaining a
speed of point 0 0 1 8 C December 17th
2011 fragment trajectory confirmed to
end in a collision with earth with
estimated impact of December 21st Thoth
station deterrence procedure fails at
changing fragments course public
announcement made by the United Nations
evacuations begin December 21st 2011
fragment impacts in the Pacific Ocean
124 km/h 24 2011 SCP 2845 believed to
reach shore on this day December 25th
2011 first observation of SCP 2845
through civilian video footage drone
contact made SCP 2845 confirmed as
hostile foundation assets within United
States military begin to
action of recovery and containment
procedures with assistance of global
occult coalition representatives
foundation containment sites in the
region enter lockdown December 26th to
December 29th 2011 artillery bombardment
of SCP 28 45 commences along with
initial battery of tests contact with
outside containment consultants made at
this time upon observation of SCP 28 45
s properties December 30th 2011 SCP 28
45 is unimpeded for 16 hours December
31st 2011 bombardment recommences
January 1st to January 14 2012 SCP 28:45
is led across the Sierra Nevada
mountains while remaining under heavy
bombardment develops initial containment
procedures January 15 2012
SCP 28:45 reaches predetermined
containment area initial containment
procedures enacted January 18 2012
initial containment procedures end in
success January 20th 2012 construction
of site 100 begins february 3rd 2012
refinements of containment procedures
implemented february 19 2012 SCP 28:45
declared contained
all right I think that about does it for
today thank you all for listening if
indeed you still are and you were all
dismissed
goodbye I would like to give a special
thank you to researcher Brandon Connell
Burlington the cop slump of God
Justin day Pierce M Hamlin white crew
beware 600 Bryson Billy my archive
theater Nick Tiger ball Judi Dench
cheese whip the Android the
administrator quartz 5 6 3 and tree hero
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos on some
other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com forward slash the Volgin
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
you